今日は初めて町と旭取締役です双眼鏡ってご存知でしょうか
知ってますかすってますマッハだ春パーっていうんですねこれ島こういうものが見える
んですけども
やはり一つの双眼鏡だと限界があるとある程度の距離のところまでしか見えないので
めちゃくちゃ遠くのものを盗み見したいなあと思った時にこれだけだとちょっと見え
ないと
入部で起きてしまいますというふうに今日はですねこの草案今日をたくさん準備しまし
た
はいはい17うっていうなう
なんで中途半端合計17個てそう環境を準備しました
で今回なんですけどもうちょっと限界まで双眼鏡の限界はで迫ろうと思ってこれ
予選に目に見える倍率が上がるわけじゃないですかなんでこれを考察ドッキングさせる
とこれであの
10倍の距離が見るとしますってこれが10倍の給料日これとこれを掛け合わせると何
倍になるでしょう
他
[音楽]
二次会なんですよそれを育て30体正しくやい中盤にかけるじゃいま
100そういうことですよ奪いさっきのものまで見えてしまうということになります
12倍だ
ポッんじゃーすごい72倍かける12枚で借用中4枚まで見ます
うに見えるの12倍が17があるので10人の17上旬にかける12月中に限る12角
の中にかける中にかけて順次拡充にかける中にかける中にかける中にかける中にかける
中にかける12拡充にかける中にかける12が肉眼で見える場合うちになります
もう千里眼ですよ開けていきましょう
だけで17この双眼鏡がここには揃えましたまあとりあえず35まで22-10条はへ
619よく1736万葉線に124倍でございますこんなにいらないんだよね絶好です
チェックで6005階までなるから
今回僕がやりたいのは山に入る人みたいな
てその山に入る人とか
何か物とかみてたらすごいいいなと思ったんですけどた619奥歯まで入れないと思う
んで
8コだったらちなみにヨング2,998万円延べ196倍
それでも4駆バイカーん
洋9倍もいらないんだよな
830,0001808あってがあれだぜ今回の1曲なんですけど
で雅紀くんに山に行ってもらいます前提がおかしいじゃん何言ってもらって手間ネイル
馬崎を超えてみると
で1個であーちょっとボーイなーって思ったらもう一個付けたします
ピータースなら買ってってあーこれすごいはを今カーテンが
原子レベルで見えませんって嘘しっかりまず見て見てあぁちょっと遠いなって思ったら
もう1コってピント明日で付けたスティック
それでもちょっと遠いなって思ったら応募1個運動さを突き出して行くとを繰り返して
半周的に山にいる彼をしっかりとこうネタ
見れたら
いいね
て美味しくでございますそれではさっそく雅紀くんに山に入ってもらいましょう
第号パイプというわけで今雅紀くんお邪魔の方に行かせております
はいということで今高いところ撃っ割っております
投擲所きてきたあっ入ってまーず一定とりあえず着いたの売って量が送った
5ホグタイ
まず俺とかしてるんだよえっこれは俺のおっちゃんだよこれ
あっハープ母はアーマー頭数キャバ以降
通してだけだよ今ちょっと陰でしてみますもう持ってる
th
ステンドけど解こう a 全く起こらないよ本当に
ガーネイルでしょ余っちゃったら by てくれたただできればねガードレールが
るってすごい助かるかもしれないわかったわかったじゃあちょっと移動してみるお願い
します
です end 10ブルー
ええええ
まんっ
hey
うん
犬可愛いまず人どっちがかわいいいるさようなら
だっていいですね
法王は hey
そこが俺の大切な大切なんですか
ちょっとねぇ了解しましたらちょっともうたぶん相手を変わらずが見えないんで早速
相談教育を使って見ていきます
神戸でしたかっ
以下だったらやっぱり不是いざガードレール r はダメだろ
から触れるまあ横に立ってるガードいるによっこちょっと探してみます
ガードレールがすぐ場合ん
まずこれか
今だぞ入れの前にいる
カーサデルとお前相談今日一つでも小さすぎて確認できないのでまず竜合体させてみ
ましょう
これだかなりめちゃくちゃ誓ったことまで見えるようになると思うんで
collect 雅紀くんを結構早く見つけられるとかなと思いますはいで良さが出て
いきます
[音楽]
ええええええ
ねぇ2ですよねはいまでも見えません
ん
道央
[音楽]
me
uh
バッハ